a Pima cotton blend t-shirt on Vince's
site costs 85 dollars but the same shirt
sells for 29.99 at TJ Maxx so why does
it cost less over 10 years the off-price
retailer has opened 263 more stores in
2022 TJX which owns TJ Maxx Marshalls
and Home Goods brought in almost 50
billion dollars in sales revenue more
than Nordstrom's and Macy's combined and
the secret to its success the company
isn't shifting most of its business
online or using big data to figure out
what Shoppers want instead it's sticking
to a decades-old Playbook
[Music]
this is the economics of TJ Maxx there
are really two components to TJ Maxx's
strategy the bargain and the hunt One
Way TJ Maxx gets discounted Goods is by
buying excess merchandise and canceled
orders from other brands and retailers
essentially it takes advantage of
surplus and waste in the retail system
this allows the company to sell its
merchandise generally around 20 to 60
percent below regular retail prices but
there's a catch just the fact that the
price is low is not enough what you need
is also a reference price because people
don't know how much things cost that's
where Alex says something known as the
anchoring effect comes in at TJ Maxx
most items have two prices the TJ Maxx
price and a comparison price people
anchoring it in a regular price and then
they see exactly how much of a deal
they're getting
and this way they really understand what
the value is that TJ Maxx provides to
them take these Rag and Bone shorts a TJ
Maxx in Manhattan sold them for about
forty dollars with a comparison price of
fifty dollars that's a 20 discount but
the original price tag happened to be on
these shorts and it lists the price as
195 dollars that would be around an 80
discount and that comparison price is
really just an estimate on TJ Maxx's
website there's a message next to the
comparison price that says these prices
are references to regular retail prices
where identical items are not available
we compare to products of a similar type
quality and style these price tags
aren't the only way TJ Maxx helps
customers feel like they're getting a
bargain at the co-positioning of TJ Maxx
is uh if we give you brand names for
Less
and the reason why it's important is
because very often when you see low
price uh you think it's low price
because the quality of the product is
low but if the customer knows and trusts
the brand then they won't assume the
price is low because it's a bad product
instead Alex says they'll attribute it
to TJ Maxx's ability to get discounted
goods and because people often expect
name brand items to be more expensive
the brand itself acts as an anchor
emphasizing the fact that as a customer
you're getting a deal
uh makes people feel good it's not only
I'm getting a low price but I'm actually
getting a deal
uh which makes people feel good about
themselves that they're smart Shoppers
TJ Maxx says it gets its goods from
about 21 000 vendors and the inventory
in its stores is constantly turning so
as a result people tend to go more often
to this type of stores and also spend a
little bit more time in the store in
search of something across its companies
TJX employs more than 1200 buyers that
each control millions of dollars and has
authority to cut deals on the spot as a
buyer for TJ Maxx I'm always on the hunt
let's say you have a bathing suit brand
and it's the right before Memorial Day
weekend and they're stuck with extra
bathing suits that's when TJ Maxx buyers
show up at the showroom you know they
can cut a deal right on the spot and
they can get it to their stores within a
week department stores on the other hand
can take weeks to review and approve
orders from their buyers so TJ Maxx buys
the merchandise quickly and gets it into
the store just as fast they have been
saying internally door to floor in 24
meaning that any merchandise that shows
up at a store in the morning has to be
on the sales floor by the end of that
day to ensure speed merchandise often
arrives at stores already on racks that
employees wheel off trucks and move
straight onto the sales floor and once
it's there all the merchandise is laid
out differently than other retailers too
helping to create that treasure hunt
experience while most department stores
group items by brand TJ Maxx organizes
its inventory by type this means that
different brands can end up next to each
other on the same racks and since TJ
Maxx doesn't have walls dividing
sections of the stores or Brands it can
easily reconfigure the layout based on
changing inventory seeing all the
products and changing layout can
encourage impulse buying Shoppers know
that if they see something they like
they need to buy it now if they wait it
may be sold out or hard to find when
they come back once you take it home
things are changing dramatically because
now you're not buying something you are
giving up something lots of research has
shown that giving up something is more
difficult than acquiring you're willing
to pay more
not to give up something then to buy
something retailers struggled through
the rise of e-commerce in the pandemic
and while tjx's off-price retailers
still took a hit they have bounced back
in 2021 TJX had the highest sales in the
company's history a record it then beat
the following year and it's not because
TJ Maxx and the other off-price
retailers adapted but rather because
they never drifted away from their core
strategy TJ Maxx tends to perform pretty
well in an economic downturn because
that's when customers tend to be bargain
conscious and you know they offer really
good value for the money
[Music]